et voilà les premiers mots de jean
castex se mettent à l'assemblée
nationale le premier ministre qui a
planté le décor première crise une crise
plutôt économique inédite à venir et un
gouvernement je le cite deux combats de
dialogue et de territoires alors est ce
la fin de l'idée de start up nation cher
au président le nouveau chemin que veut
tracer emmanuel macron passe-t-il par
une nouvelle doctrine économique cdde
objet de notre face à face ce soir et
pour en parler nous sommes avec alexis
poulain cofondateur du monde moderne
bonsoir alexis poulain à vos côtés loïk
le floch prigent ancien grand dirigeant
d'entreprise bonsoir à vous également
loïk le floch prigent alors baptême du
feu aujourd'hui pour le premier ministre
tout d'abord petite question à l'analyse
que vous êtes alexis blanc vous l'avez
trouvé comment ce premier ministre
plutôt à l'aise devant les députés
oui plutôt à l'aise alors il va falloir
s'habituer au style castex qui est quand
même d'une certaine lenteur de ces
ampoules et il ya l'accent donc c'est
c'est particulier on n'est pas habitué à
ça l'on n'avait edouard philippe qui
était quand même un peu plus vif un peu
plus moderne
il ya un côté un peu suranné dans la
façon de s'exprimer de jean castex qui
fait que b on est tendu à sa parole on
attend un peu quand ça arrive les
parfois c'est un peu long à arriver
après il sait très bien ce qu'il veut il
l'a dit il a les valeurs qui sont les
siennes le faire un gouvernement de
combat
il n'est pas dupe il sait que ce qui
arrive est une crise économique d'une
ampleur inédite
maintenant qu'ils parlent de
gouvernement de combat très bien on
aimerait savoir avec quelles armes ce
gouvernement va aller au combat
alors on va voir ses armes un
gouvernement dont combat diallo
territoire
on est loin loïk le floch prigent de
cette idée de start up nation cher
emmanuel macron on est loin dans les
mots mais maintenant il faut transformer
les mots en actions alors sur la team
dans simple il ya deux ou trois choses à
faire
et on va le juger les mots sur les
actions pas la peine de continuer à
passer du temps sur les mots uniquement
sur les mots la première chose c'est que
nos entreprises ont à cailloux dans la
chaussure qui est celui des impôts de
production inventer quand on a enlevé la
thèse professionnelle dont combat à 3 6%
dans la chaussure
c'est à dire que on est trois vers les 6
% qui en rêve la marge
alors est ce que oui ou non on entend
les seules entreprises et les salariés
qui depuis des années disent pourquoi à
ton change et atteint professionnel pour
avoir proféré 6% qui sont un problème
vis-à-vis hongroise haras national on
est sujet deuxième juge et aux
industriels
est ce que on arrête de considérer que
l'ensemble de l'industrie est coupable
coupable dans ses recoins mais coupable
et à chaque fois qui a une occasion de
lui dire demain le qu'on pense d'elle on
le fait alors hier c'était il faut
absolument vous allez en chômage partiel
le lendemain il faut surtout que vous
soyez sachez bien que le tomates
anciennes va être contrôlé ensuite
orient on vous envoie les inspecteurs du
travail
ensuite on a l'instinct de
l'environnement qui voici foi peut faire
il faut envoyer pour sauver le climat
les inspecteurs du fisc c'est à dire que
les entreprises sont effectivement
depuis des années mais surtout depuis
quelques mois à la main d administration
qui disent vous êtes mauvais vous êtes
méchant vous n'êtes pas bien et il faut
vous alliez d'embranchements je pense
qu'il faut un moment avoir un discours
bienveillant bienveillant à l'égard des
industriels et ce discours bienveillante
boîte heures suivie en dehors des mots
des prêts des chefs d'état comme des
ministres et des présidents et des
premiers ministres
il faut soit suivre effet les faits
c'est ça c'est nous voulons avoir une
administration bienveillante dans les
années
le qui viennent et surtout dans les mois
qui viennent bienveillante dire que nous
ne sommes pas en train d'essayer de
faire de l'argent sur des salariés ce
n'est pas vrai et les salariés on y
travaille et voilà la situation de
calais alors si je mets en attestent ces
notions à ce moment là on pourra dire
qui a peut-être un gouvernement de
combat
et quand on regarde les territoires mais
bon l'instant je ne ferai moi je n'ai
que des mots alexis poulain vous êtes
d'accord on n'a que des démos ses tâches
ou alors c'est un chemin économique
radicalement différent que nous nous
apprêtons à prendre comment vous vous
sentez les choses mais cette présidence
de façon à celle de la communication
politique à outrance on a beaucoup de
beaux et très peu d'action et on a
toujours des discours on attend
d'ailleurs le discours du 14 juillet de
vannes elle mâcon qui a précédé le
discours de jean castex choses assez
inédite pour une fois encore passer de
la pommade lancé de grands discours mais
évidemment ce sont les faits qu'ils
feront que la france pourra sortir de
cette crise internationale la tête haute
et bien à genoux et là tels que c'est de
présenter aujourd'hui on peut avoir peur
d'une vente à la découpe de faillite
masse il d'ailleurs emmanuel macron le
disait lors d'une allocution précédentes
et je ne vois pas aujourd'hui comment il
pourrait changer sa politique pour
justement éviter le krach a annoncé
c'est le drame français c'est à dire
qu'on a à la fois des énarques qui sont
à la tête de l'état et à la tête des
entreprises et ces gens là ont une
certaine vision des choses de commandes
vrai marché des entreprises ou hui trop
souvent le tissu économique que sont les
pme les tpe
or c'est le poumon économique à la fois
en france mais aussi en europe et
ailleurs et c'est ce qui fait le succès
de l'allemagne par exemple en france on
a des dieux que pour le cac40 qui parce
que justement ça permet quand on est une
arme de passer de la cour cac 40 un coup
au gouvernement et vice versa c'est pas
ça l'économie l'économie c'est un tout
et je crois que les chefs d'entreprise
aujourd'hui ont effectivement besoin
d'être rassuré mais plus que être
assurée c'est s'assurer que l'activité
va pouvoir reprendre
le confinement tel qu'il a été celle de
manière massive il a peut-être permis
d'endiguer cette circulation du virus
mais il nous emmène tout droit vers une
crise économique d'une ampleur inédite
et malheureusement les aides d'état
devons faire que creuser la dette et ne
vont pas sauver autant d'entreprises que
qui va être annoncé dans les discours
combatif de jean castex ou des modèles
maintenant c'est vrai que la crise
économique voilà il fait plutôt peur
parce que jean castex parler d'une crise
économique la plus difficile depuis 1929
il agite le chiffon rouge le premier
ministre où il est dans la réalité le
club présent je cours je pense qu'il
faut raison garder c'est à dire que on
dit que la pandémie est exceptionnelle
et que par conséquent c'est normal que
tout ce qui arrive on l'apprend amy n'a
pas été exceptionnelle elle a été elle a
généré la peur la peur est générée par
le discours gouvernemental mais disons
que il ya eu des morts sublet beaucoup
plus important là les belles bagnoles et
la grippe peuvent donc on n'est pas seul
c'est exceptionnel surtout dans les mots
alors en l'occurrence en ce qui concerne
les entreprises et on va dire aux
industriels caraïbes au sens l'emploi
c'est les pme tpe
c'est pas aller bien reprise aura
aujourd'hui on se met à parler rebeu
regardez c'est terrible mais non c'est
pas ça le sujet le sujet ce sont les
petits des entreprises et les aider les
entreprises aux temps intermédiaires qui
ont souffert qui ont été demandés
quelques sous en trésorerie qui les ont
eu raison plus grossièrement seulement
la moitié d'entre elles ont eu les
brèmes langil par l'état donc saisir et
c'est un premier problème de réseau riz
et derrière il y a le le fait qu' on est
on est en train les interroger
aujourd'hui point bas savoir si ayant
eut touché chômage partiel il y avait
vraiment drôle si ils ont bien fait tout
ce qu'il fallait pour l'environnement
6,6 à plat et je pense que si
l'inspection du travail 6 mai et qu'elle
nous dit que effectivement on a mal agi
avec les salariés alors ça lol le le le
ce sera salle comble en salle gaulle
avec ses poulains
problème il faut qu'on rêve c'est à dire
c'est que nous acceptons de
bienveillants à l'égard des entreprises
et des pme et des tpe ou pas ce problème
n'est pas réglé et tous les chefs
d'entreprise pourrait vous le dire à l
excellent vous êtes d'accord avec ce
soit ce diagnostic parce que pardonnez
moi je vous coupe mais mais quand même
si on a été un des systèmes les plus
généreux du monde retourne et bombay
quand même la moitié des salariés du
privé au chômage mais actuelles je crois
que c'est c'est on est généreux mais au
prix d'une tête qui galonnés mais qu'est
ce que vous voyez monsieur roulier faire
quoi je n'ai pas une solution
heureusement qu'on a pu avoir ce matelas
mais malheureusement on n'a fait que
retarder le saut dans le vide
c'est à dire que oui certaines
entreprises ont reçu des aides elles
vont pouvoir aider le chômage partiel va
faire qu'on va demander beaucoup
d'efforts aux salariés en disant que
vous allez travailler plus et gagner
beaucoup moins parce que sinon c'est la
porte alors qu'on aurait pu peut-être
essayer de préserver l'activité
c'est pas le fait seulement de la france
bien sûr cette crise est mondiale et la
réponse a été malheureusement tardi dans
l'urgence et ce qui fait qu'on est
aujourd'hui en train de gérer avec deux
trois mois de retard ce qui est en train
de se passer
donc on ne va pas éviter malheureusement
l'entrée de de milliers de français dans
le chômage de certains dans la précarité
les unes des nombreuses faillites
et ça c'est dommageable mais il n'y a
pas de solution magique bien entendu on
est volé les 35 heures ont réécrit code
du travail qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
je conteste complètement que le chômage
partiel célébrée comme une victoire est
était effectivement et victoire
considère qu' il fallait donner aux
entreprises dans la mesure du possible
nous continuer à travailler en prenant
les précautions nécessaires pour la
santé ce ce qui a été fait dans en
allemagne ai-je lu raison est encore
redémarré une entreprise après que de
l'ensemble de l'entreprise soit c'est
chez elle pendant un ou deux mois
c'est très difficile et nous vivons ce
problème ans donc j'ai entreprise de
façon frontale et virait
extrêmement difficile donc premièrement
deuxièmement je crois que maintenant il
faut que tout le monde si matt
effectivement et qu' il faut laisser aux
entreprises la possibilité de discuter
avec leurs salariés pour faire les
choses si jamais on continue à faire les
politiques nationales et asmar est
d'aider les affaires avec des grenades
différentes et variées
on peut pas s'en sortir on peut s'en
sortir que le dirigeant d'entreprise
avec ses salariés qui voilà comment on
fait maintenant pour y arriver et ça ça
se fait naturellement
si jamais on les laisserait ainsi donc
on communique pas autant qu'on
communique la communication
gouvernementale est est
catastrophiquement dans un confinement
et si je mets continue la catastrophique
eh bien nous irons la catastrophe mais
c'est sûrement en partie importante
parce que la communication a été folle
que nous sommes dans ces situations
complètement rocambolesque
merci à tous les 2 alexis poulain loïk
le floch prigent d'avant était avec nous